oh hey everyone I'm Ilana or char
Alana's on and this is Forza horizon 2 I
haven't played it yet so this is gonna
be my first time playing it which you
guys will be able to join me on of
course it is developed by turn 10 the
people who make all of the Forza games
I'm pretty excited i since i played this
at Gamescom have been really looking
forward to it but i guess we'll have to
see you only ah so inconvenient while
you do this actually pronounced it wrong
i think that a lot of countries do this
I'm not sure but it's supposed to be
pronounced fort sir so I say Forza
almost Australian safe Forza so I it's
suppose to be like pizza so I guess it
would be like for so I Danny I bet they
can anointed that though I'd be
frustrated but maybe if they spelt it
like fo ah TSA itted wait make way more
sense for Tzu use the driving then hope
you drive it the gas okay things are
happening so excited open your eyes
listen closely to the sound of my voice
okay with every word and every number
you move faster and faster it talks like
that on the count of 10
you will be in horizon I will kill you
temptress I say one your pulse begins to
quicken to your friends rattle in the
backseat it's not how you race that way
sacado I'm living theatre and fast tell
my shindig head friends to get out of
the backseat they're ruining my sweets
beads your thoughts begin to wash away
in a cloud of wind and us five colored
lights flurry in the distance so what is
this some festive a simulator light
shutters know what I signed up for every
said corvo attano from dismal don't haze
sign up for that seven half mad racing
game oft is a little faster and faster
into infinity hey the crowd in tears
what is this festival hmm you cross into
a larger more colourful world on the
count of ten
everything you've ever known fades away
it doesn't sound good i don't want that
you will be in horizon don't say 10 I
like what I know oh I'm scared now and
screen went black is that me is that me
being blind do I lost my sight or if
you've done to me devil woman oh I
should start making fun of everything
it's a thing that I do it's not make fun
of this game I'm actually excited about
it it's pretty so far fantastic news the
beef debt of entire arsenal has want to
get her married off there will be a
massive ground and not to see your class
so take it easy when you coming off the
phone
deadass the road you can put your foot
down so excited just let me drive it
come on festival tonight ready ready
ready
re re it's not a race to get there but
might be lost to a rock on its mayara if
that's how you pronounce I'm still not
sure why ara I think it's a why arrow
that's how they say I don't know I still
brothers and oh it's just a taste this
only watch summer of all much sleep
lately plan i might clean it
and ice
Oh / did that okay this car feels on
heavy
I'll switch the camera like like this
oh no oh no this pedestrian cause that's
gonna be bad okay
so I figure the festival thing right is
because this game is supposed to be set
in the
horizon festival is just like a car
racing thing I suppose so the music he
gets with the I assure part of the
festival
I also assume not actually owner I'm not
actually part of the game
yeah direction haven't really spoken
about this on my channel before you guys
but I'm actually a big fan of cause
I think it's oh oh oh no no need you
not going to stop it um I think it's
actually video games kind of got me into
cars
so decide upon code names and arcade
racing
and kind of got into project gotham
racing and
backorder cost of raising three for a
while
any time in my life that I've ever been
grounded I don't know what is grab
things for like sneaking out
yeah over the two weeks that I've
grounded it was on to the holidays hey
it's been so that was the girl it's a
best part I know you wanna first people
in Europe to drive that thing there's a
lot of physical the festival went
together
so let's get it there in one piece yeah
I'm on it oh oh no oh that was good I
don't know why I saw it there and was
like you know what I should do I should
not scare in any direction I should
continue which isn't looking right at it
oh Jesus that's another time
not what I expected
oh no my dog has awoken
it's not a good time Bobby little
superjet race
I do like the even category course
country but I was expecting to be able
to do a bit more than what I'm just
doing here there's expecting like actual
yeah nevermind disregard everything I
was just about to say hey screw you guy
fight me get out of your con fighting
immediately GTA style you like tap the
button which plays along
ah
does for super heavy
what up guys you're listening to bass
arena coming at you from amazing
festival where the cars are rolling in
the party has started and the heads are
any air come on get down here people Oh
brew and that's why everyone interesting
choice of potty though uh oh no
rewinding yeah I like how we like refers
to this is a party when you know just
lots of lots of street racing going on
I've already crashed into a bunch come
on man I haven't sucked a bunch penis
cause my kind of party hey
what up
Oh Haram the ointment
where are the cops like really lets me
really sings have cop cars everywhere if
they know people gonna just rock up
thank you bye hey I did so what do you
think perfect mixture music and machines
right this was a long time in the making
but it's totally worth it tomorrow
morning you're gonna get fresh cars then
we're off on our first road trip but
tonight welcome to Horizon it really
wasn't expecting that I don't think I've
ever seen that in this kind of game
before oh my god dog what are you doing
so my dog just got desexed right which
means that she has a con on her head so
that she can't um scratch herself so she
just sees making a lot of noise thanks
dawg Chelsea stop it what are you doing
giddy it drop like video games god damn
it Jessie
alright well now thanks for your help
yesterday there's only so many cars a
guy can drive it once you know suffers
in July head level so pretty oh so
pretty you're gonna need a car to get
through the horizon hits take your pick
from one of these
I do like my BMWs but we are going to go
with a Subaru because supra okay the
supra good choice thank you I know it is
what are we doing man what are we doing
this is your map of the verizon festival
icons like this one represent key phases
in event of the festival the horizon
heat is a great chance for you to try it
Chelsea shut up set a route there now
alright well let's go then all right
I'll see you that
okay cool i forgot to say all of our
cars come pre tuned to three festival
radio stations horizon bass arena
horizon excess and horizon pulse I'm
happy about that I do you think that
good soundtrack is important in a racing
game
that's pretty
it's car looks unrealistically shiny
though
oh ah we're organizing a little cost
between you and your friends at the
festival you need to drive past these
speed traps as fast as you can try it
out because that's what a speed cameras
of use for as you probably already know
try as many times as you like try to
give yourself the best one I could care
okay 200 meters I think I'll be a little
bored at the mall right
else my friends played it yet so let's
just say I'm winning and winning for the
next like two days or something okay so
that's cool the crossroad stuff there
was big ticket equal I like that firstly
what everyone I just need to drive up to
its marker and confirm you want to enter
all right let's enter let's do a thing
in the suite supra hashtag jdn
I'm so ready okay let me do it let me do
it do it no AI drivers are horizon all
the opponents your face here are the
driver tars of real people driving in
the same way they do some of them will
be your friend so if you beat them be
sure she will tricks time you speak I am
friends with him are you ready to put
those new wheels to the test yes this is
the horizon heat okay let me start
finishing the top three and you get your
festival wristband that's the ticket to
the road trip of your life okay go get
it huh yes we can have a look at
churning tuning allows you to really get
down to the tiny details tire pressure
gear ratios suspension settings whatever
you want you can tweak it here okay
choices
interesting Oh Chuck all the negative
camber on it they're all locked at the
moment though as far as I can tell so
maybe it's stuff that you just have to
okay well that's all looked but that
does seem pretty extensive which is
awesome so start race time let's do it
I'm ready
almost all people
apparently they're all really bad I
never deceive any ants
I don't know who three people but I do
know the others were just going
this
I guess the question very different
cause and a lamp
I guess okay this coin is better that's
immediately audience yeah it's
definitely comes better still screwed it
up but it does which is cool way better
that's crazy
definitely feels a lot slower
probably feels equally amount of heavy i
think it's just that it's not like maybe
it's just I didn't know I was doing that
um maybe this is just maintain that top
repossessed okay we've done cars and
I've tried so far but it feels like it's
not responding to
liquids white immediately
as I would like
you've got a false then surely all right
it's okay still in it
this game is super pretty though hey
super pretty I really like all that
whatever one's too that's cool oh damn
I'm so not used to these Arkady kind of
games having them good physics like
driving over the cuirass actually makes
a difference and just hitting that bin
back there actually made a difference it
didn't just like let me continue like
nothing can happen which is my first
clean that's what I'm not like you yeah
you take that Eminem bet you guys didn't
know that Eminem and I are good friends
how all these people already played it
this is crazy what do you this game
wasn't even out yet maybe it is out of
that one confused but I feel like I did
pretty good job there nice one nailed it